good evening welcome thank you so much
everyone for coming
I'm Martina draweth I'm the deputy
director of research and curator of
sculpture at the Yale Center for British
art across the street and on behalf of
all of my colleagues at the centre and
here at the Yale University art gallery
I'm really delighted to welcome you to
this Andrew conative Richie program
which is a program that's co-sponsored
by the two museums and we're absolutely
delighted to welcome in Kashani bar a
and B er a to Yale welcome and it's my
great pleasure to introduce both yanker
and our colleague Coburn Hermosa
professor of art history and
african-american studies here at Yale
this program is coincides with a focused
exhibition at the Yale Center for
British art we have on display seven of
yunkish Ronnie burrows work works
alongside three of his films and we'll
be screening the film's after this talk
ends Janka was born and educated in
London but he also spent much of his
youth in Nigeria where his parents are
from and this dual experience of two
places of two cultures as I know many of
you are very familiar with his work in
that background but that informs very
much his art he studied at Byam Shaw
School of Art and then at Goldsmith
where he did his MFA and graduated with
that generation that we know as the yba
is the young British artists and it's
interesting to remember that back in
1997 his work was included in sensation
which was kind of a defining exhibition
of that generation although maybe in
this country it's best remembered for
the huge political storm that engulfed
it when it opened in in Brooklyn in 2002
he was commissioned to make a major work
for document at 10 which was an
important moment for his international
career and this was followed by his
nomination for the Turner Prize in 2004
an exhibition at the Venice Biennale in
2007 and a string of major exhibitions
all around the world
since in 2011 he made his first public
sculpture
Nelson's ship-in-a-bottle for the so
called fourth plinth in Trafalgar Square
in London and we have an addition of the
maquette that he made for that
commission on view across the street I
don't think it's an exaggeration to say
that this work really turns upside down
pretty much everything that we might
expect from or associate with public
sculpture especially in the context of
this site for which this work was
conceived Trafalgar Square this most
Imperial of public spaces right at the
heart of London named after the military
hero Admiral Nelson and his victory at
the Battle of Trafalgar and incurs
intervention or interruption into this
space had the effect of in a sense
unveiling or making newly and
differently visible the powerful
historic symbols that mark so many of
our public spaces and which remains so
deeply embedded in our culture that
sometimes they can hide very well in
plain sight these historical themes and
figures which Jonker engages with are
precisely those that characterize our
museums in many ways and our historic
collections and the centre has from for
a decade for more longer than a decade
actively engaged in the examination of
the legacies of colonialism and Empire
which is so much part of the traditions
of the art that we own that we display
and our presentation of incas work at
the centre this fall coincides very
purposefully with a major exhibition
curated by our former colleague Eleanor
Hughes who's now the Walters on 18th
century marine paintings which traces
the relationship between painting
traditions and Britain's rise as an
imperial maritime power and that show
which is on our third floor at the
center ends with Nelson and the Battle
of Trafalgar of 1805 and of course this
is where Yonker in a sense picks up the
story in our exhibition refracted
through his lens and and through the
present it's been my great pleasure to
work with with yanker his many
colleagues from
are here with him also with his gallery
in New York and especially I'd like to
thank Jane Cohen for all her work on
helping to develop the exhibition and
this program and our dialogue will carry
forward into the spring when we will
open a new exhibition to examine the
role of female royal patronage in the
long 18th century and Jonker will be
creating a special piece for that show
and we're really excited to be
continuing to work with him the incus
work is owned by many public collections
including the Smithsonian Institution
the Brooklyn Museum the Art Institute of
Chicago at the Boston MFA the V&A I
could go on but really I wanted to
mention that we can add to that list at
the Yale Center for British art as we
have acquired two of his works one is a
print collage and the other is a large
photographic piece from his series the
fake death pictures which relates very
directly to our historic collections in
that it's takes its cue from a
pre-raphaelite painting by Henry Wallace
depicting the death of Chatterton and
those works are both on display at the
center so tonight is a very special
opportunity to hear from yanker and from
Koba Nomura who is here at Yale and
writes and teachers on the visual arts
of the black diaspora examining African
American Caribbean and black British
artists in modern and contemporary art
and kobena was one of the earliest
scholars to engage critically and
analytically with what Janka was doing
and in 1995 he published an article in
in frieze magazine which was titled art
that is ethnic in inverted commas on
Jenka Shauna berry which really for the
first time addressed some of the
conceptual and historical issues at work
in the incas art in the interim of
course so much has been written on
yonkers work that we might take those
conceptual issues more for granted now
but they were not to be taken granted
for taken for granted then and more than
20 years on urbanist texts and his
continuing engagement with with yonkers
work and and other peers continues to
provide a foundational touchstone for
for how we think about his art coburn
his first book the seminal collection
welcome to the jungle of 1994
transform debates and thinking around
race and representation and he has since
then written many monographic studies on
artists amongst others Isaac Julian who
was here recently he added he edited the
annotating arts history series published
by MIT and in Evert and he's the
inaugural recipient of the 2006 Clark
prize for excellence in arts writing
which was awarded by the Clark Art
Institute in Williamstown his recent
book is is called
travel and see black diaspora art
practices since the 1980s and it's just
come out from Duke given Coburn has
long-standing engagement with yonkers
work and in shaping some of the larger
scholarly context around it I'm really
delighted that we have this opportunity
to have both Kona and Janka here for
this public conversation I want to thank
the many people that helped make this
program happen and our two guests please
join me in welcoming them
okay well good evening everyone
my thanks to Martina for the
introduction as well so it's a real
pleasure for me to introduce yokocho
Newbury MBE
to Yale and our campus community here
and our focus for our conversation this
evening is the body of work that you
incur has produced which addresses the
figure of Admiral Horatio Nelson and
this includes some of the works that
have been recently acquired for the
collection at Yale Center for British
art so I'm wondering if we might start
at the beginning with the maquette that
you produced in 2007 for your purse
first public sculpture which was
Nelson's ship-in-a-bottle of 2010 when
it was installed in Trafalgar Square so
what we're seeing in the maquette is a
miniature of the HMS Victory and we
notice straightaway that the canvas
sales have been rendered in Dutch wax
print fabric so what's the history of
this fabric and could you say a little
bit about how you came to choose it as
your signature material in your practice
Oh first of all I should say thank you
very much for inviting me it's a
pleasure to be here and you know I would
like to share some of my some of the
ideas in my work you know with you and
you know where all of this started now
I'm well known for using the fabrics in
my work known as African textiles and
indeed in I was born in London but I
grew up in Nigeria and I grew up
thinking the fabrics were made in West
Africa I realized this after I'd been at
college in London and the context of
that at the time I was actually at
college I was trained as a traditional
painter
I used to do life drawing life painting
and all that and then I think in my
second year at college I became quite
political in the work that I wanted to
do and so I started making work about
what was going on in Russia and I was
making work about perestroika and I
figured that was the citizen of the
world and I could engage with pretty
much anything as I grew up in a
cosmopolitan city like Legos and in
London well to my surprise my tutor said
well why you making work about Russia
what's that got to do with you
why aren't you producing authentic
African art now the the notion of
authenticity was then the thing I
started to explore what does
authenticity mean that's a rather
difficult one for somebody with my kind
of background I I can't be authentically
African nor can I be authentically
British so then what am I I then decided
to go to Brixton market it's a market in
London where I had actually seen the
fabrics you know being sold in the shops
then I went into the shop and I started
talking to them about the fabrics and
they told me well the fabrics actually
were made in in Holland the fabrics are
Indonesian influenced fabrics produced
by the Dutch and then for sales
you know foster tried Indonesia the
industrial production wasn't perhaps not
as attractive so they tried West Africa
and the fabrics were successful there
but the layer of irony that I actually
like when a lot of the African countries
became independent
from britain in the 50s people actually
wanted to wear non-western clothes so
those fabrics then were adopted but I
like the paradox of something to express
your own African individuality you're
then actually appropriating something
then which is Western so is the fabric
then authentic or not and so
conceptually that's the reason why I
start using those fabrics so in relation
to a battleship which is what HMS
Victory was which enabled the British to
defeat the Spanish at the Battle of
Trafalgar in 1805 how does that first
tree influence our understanding a
history of the fabric how does that
inflect our understanding of the event
the Battle of Trafalgar so in London
there is a blimp an empty plinth in
Trafalgar Square and it's a space that's
used for temporary public sculpture and
so you know about I guess quite a number
of artists are asked to send in a
proposal for that plinth and I was
invited to send in a proposal now
Trafalgar Square is very you know very
very public space within the hour you
might have about a million people going
through I mean it's a very busy point
and all around you on the square there
are kind of you know generals and there
is Nelson's column and and I wanted to
do something that would relate to the
context of the square and the plinth and
Nelson's column is next the plinth and
you know Trafalgar Square
I then researched you know trophy
the Battle of Trafalgar happened in 1805
and Nelson had a battle with Napoleon
and anyway Nelson won that battle the
British won and then the British were
able to actually have freedom of the
Seas
if Napoleon had lost that battle I
probably be speaking to you guys in
French now I don't know if that's a good
thing or a bad thing just saying yes so
where were we
and then I wanted to actually put HMS
Victory the flagship of Nelson into a
giant bottle I'm doing two things here
usually within the public realm public
sculpture tends to be quite serious at
Trafalgar Square anyway I wanted
something that would be serious and
playful at the same time something that
the public can actually engage with but
then would actually explore issues
around colonialism and also particularly
multicultural London London looks the
way it looks now in terms of its
population because of those you know
British adventures in the past and but
the interesting thing about this space
is people who are very nationalistic
actually thought I was celebrating
nothing and people are kind of anti
nationalistic so good on you really
subversive piece so but I like that I
like that you know people not quite
knowing what the piece is doing yeah
and we'll look at the the piste itself
in a moment but perhaps one last
question in terms of your thinking when
you produce the maquette so what led you
to the ship in a bottle
we have impossible bottles in which many
ordinary objects are placed inside a
glass container and it's something that
has a nautical origin something that's
produced in a sort of that sailors would
have produced at the end of the 18th
century I'm sure it's a question that's
come up many times before but even at
the maquette stage how did you get the
ship inside the bottle I think that I'd
have to kill you if I told you okay
right well perhaps move on to the next
question okay
that's obviously a trade secret you've
mentioned a little bit about the the
fourth plinth which when Sir Edwin
Landseer created the bronze lions to act
as guardians for Nelson's column in the
1870s the fourth one remained empty but
it's only really been in the last
fifteen years that it's become a sight
for public heart so can you walk us
through the commissioning process what
was it like after you were invited
because after all this was officially
commissioned by the Mayor of London
Boris Johnson what was the response of
the commissioning group to your proposal
well I mean I was I presented my
proposal very well
I had the maquette of the ship in a
bottle and it was very well made and
they I was in fact so that they were
actually impressed by representation and
it was just purely on the presentation
it was it was unanimous
very excited about it
but for me it was a very scary process
because when they
it starts off as a competition so then
you get a shortlist of about four and
then they display the four markets and
then the public get to vote I think the
public has got just one vote and the
committee have you know the rest and and
when I saw the names on the list
I had no experience of public sculpture
at this time so I saw you know Antony
Gormley
Anish Kapoor and I thought well that's
it you know I'm not getting it you know
but anyway I did get through and so yeah
so you know but there was no pushback in
the process in terms of no concerns
being voiced on the part of the
commissioning well no I mean everybody
said of course you can't make that you
know it's it's you know it's a huge as
my voice is going I need to drink zombie
excuse me okay I'll tell you when I have
it don't rub
it's all come on sir cells okay yeah so
I wonder whether the response because it
was so favorable has something to do
with the British having a very patriotic
relationship to their ships I mean when
the Ark Royal which played a part in the
Falklands War was decommissioned people
lined the streets but the interesting
thing is that HMS Victory has never been
decommissioned no no there's a captain I
mean I actually went to see it you know
and I'm the captain of the ship actually
came down to Trafalgar Square to see the
piece and what was his response well I
have sinned lopped it you know wanted
his photograph taken with me and
everything so we can't see the way in
which the bottle relates to the column
perhaps a little bit in this
installation view you've put the your
ship in a bottle and the column into
into a conversation you mentioned
previously just now that it was
important to open up a conversation but
what principle were you acting on in
terms of not choosing to make a
statement but rather trying to sort of
call forth a conversation and what would
you would you mean how did you avoid the
temptation of making a statement well I
mean first of all public sculpture that
they in terms of this kind of national
space is like Trafalgar Square you know
traditionally this sculpture there would
be rather didactic and it's sometimes
even jingoistic you know very
militaristic and airy as notice I am NOT
didactic I don't you know and also we do
need to put the
actually very much in the context of
post-structuralism and in the context of
a lot of the kind of French theory that
I kind of grew up with now what I mean
about that is there is a there's a
process and you know we'll talk about
that later as well but there's a a
process of challenging the grand
narratives you know people of my
generation actually what I mean by this
is looking at history and looking at my
own position as somebody of African
origin against in a Western history and
then saying actually we do need to start
unraveling of all of this and so the
reason I actually going to this or I go
into the kind of theory aspect of this
is it's actually you know my own
background has kind of informed my
approach to grand narratives so that
something which is all the authoritarian
spaces in electrophiles square I want to
actually play about in it in that space
I don't you know I can't actually
produce something didactic in that space
you know because I stole in other words
my generation we grew up really
challenging all those ideologies now
that's what we and we want to represent
or we want to represent quote-unquote
the other but we don't want to do that
in a kind of didactic manner so then
that piece is the opposite you know it
is the opposite of public sculpture
in that sense so that's really
interesting it's an aesthetic principle
of deconstruction yes you're acting on
yes almost like evoking the iconography
of power to subvert power absolutely yes
and in formal terms rather than
theoretically though how much
consideration did you give to the scale
because in a sense you super-sized a
miniature their ship in the bottle as a
source object yes so that it's almost in
conversation with this monumental public
sculpture which is Nelson's column but
where so you're playing around that
playful element comes in in terms of
scale were you thinking of that at the
maquette stage as well oh no absolutely
yes it's making something which is small
grand you know it's kind of trying to
find grandeur in the playful you know so
it's something which is kind of playful
seems grand but then it's actually you
know the grandiose is usually
intimidating but in this space it isn't
I mean it it's kind of it's playful and
other sculptures that have been
inspirational to you in terms of playing
with scale playing with the grandiose in
a way that deflates the monumental I'm
thinking perhaps of kleiss Oldenburg
well no absolutely I mean in a class
Oldenburg it's important but you see the
difference between this work and class
Oldenburg's work is well first of all
this work is site-specific and also I
think it's a work which is historically
loaded in a different way now I'm not
suggesting that clients Oldenburg's work
in if subversiveness yes it is historic
it is challenging something else but
this you know the narrative there's a
narrative which is actually embedded in
this work and that
is linked to identity
did you see so yeah so it's a it's a
much it's it's playful and yet dark
absolute ball would class Oldenburg I
don't see the darkness in it mmm yeah
and following on from that then I mean
it's pointed as well as being playful
yes would you be comfortable if that
strategy that you've employed in this
work was described as historically
revisionist would that be a adequate
description or would you be
uncomfortable with thinking of your work
here as being a revisionist account of
the Battle of Trafalgar in what sense do
you mean that do you mean that is it you
mean nostalgia's or do you mean
nostalgic no revisionist history often
wants to challenge a grand narrative by
saying that something's been left out
well there's another point of view oh no
no you know it would not be a
revisionist in that sense because
actually I'm often complicit
okay so complicity is actually central
to my practice can you say a bit more
about that huh how did it become central
I don't know if I want to be part of the
establishment or if I want to knock it
down so there is a secret in other words
there is a secret celebration of the
things that I saw that it's you know the
world is often binary in its in its
thinking you know you're either with us
or against us
but I don't actually subscribe to that
so that's what I mean that that's
actually a degree of complicity in the
things that I do you know it's not
something that's some people find easy
to understand but you know I mean I
thought I was really subversive until I
went to Buckingham Palace and I liked me
in there you know so I mean so that
emphasizes the element of irony that has
always been the way that you've
approached being playful in this very
pointed way without losing sight of that
darker history that's behind not
absolutely obvious faces public
institutions no no absolutely I mean
horrific you know some of those those
legacies are absolutely horrific you
know but at the same time I do not wish
to be perennially on the margins indeed
and I think that what the strategy of
breaking through the binaries to achieve
something that is hybrid which is I
think written into the fabric itself yes
is something that is future-oriented
it's about how what is Britain going to
become neck
it's not just focus not dwelling on the
past absolutely yes so perhaps let's
move on to Nelson's jacket and Fanny's
dress in the sense that you then focused
in on the intimate relationship between
Horatio Nelson and Frances wool would
who was actually born on the Caribbean
island of Nevis
and it's in the Caribbean context of
Nelson's service in the West Indies he
was stationed at Barbados at one point
that they they were matched and married
yes what led to your interest in their
relationship as opposed to where we
started with which is Nelson as the
national hero what led you then on to
look at the relationship between Francis
and Horatio well so as after the often
my projects tend to if you like I give
birth to new thoughts or new ideas you
know one project will lead onto another
thing so while I was researching Nelson
ship-in-a-bottle
then I did more research on Nelson and
then I found that Nelson was indeed a
very very naughty boy so he you know
he's affair with his mistress was
absolutely scandalous and you know he
was it was married and in seven years
you know for for those seven years he
saw his wife for several months of those
seven years and then he you know he was
in in love with Emma Emma Lady Hamilton
and so that and at the time that was
absolutely scandalous and she was in a
very very attractive woman and she was
also impressed by you know the fact it
won this battle you know he wants some
other battles before he finally died
in 1805 at the Battle of fog of
Trafalgar so I looked at that
relationship and then at the same time I
wanted to overlap that story with
Traviata which is Verdes opera so it's
kind of in an overlap in two stories one
fictional and one real again trevita is
about two lovers but I liked the the
kind of tragic nature of the Opera and
the tragic nature of Nelson's life so
and also in that tragedy
I saw a metaphor for the decline and
fall of Empire and that's why I made
that piece and will come on with a clip
from that in a moment but could you walk
us through the research process that led
you to recreate in such meticulous
craftsmanship these period costumes how
do you go about selecting the Dutch wax
print fabric that you choose what was
the process in each of these pieces I
mean I I have what you know in my studio
with a number of costumers over the
years I've you know depending on the
projects that I want to do and I do have
a costume books in my studio so I mean
obviously I don't so I can't sew but I
but I do design things you know and I
designed this dress and I select the
patterns on the shapes that I want and
then and I wanted to create you know
Nelson's jacket I mean there is a jacket
the original one is actually at the
Maritime Museum in Greenwich
in London and in fact the ship the
bottle is now outside my time was done
permanently because they acquired it
after the Trafalgar Square but in
relation to the costumes it's a process
of just choosing the colors I want I
mean there are a lot of formal formal
decisions being made you know in terms
of color shape and so on and so and I
think I possibly design in the way that
I paint I would design I mean a lot of
it is very visual but yes that's I think
because in Elsa's jacket we can see the
chains that clearly have a a naval
connotation you know some of the other
fabrics we see logos like the Chanel
Chanel logo the mercedes-benz logo even
the pound sterling sign and these are
incorporated into fabrics produced by
bliss Co here's a nebula and so on that
suggests both something that's alluring
it's a bliss Co fabric is a high-end
luxury product in many West Africa and
Central African markets but is there
another layer of irony that you're
building by transposing them with such
accuracy to these period costumes well I
mean it's you know that's the earliest
thing of the umbrella and the sewing
machine and you know do you know what I
mean there by that the you know the kind
of mixing of things or the you know and
so there's that kind of quirky sort of
surrealist think thing as well that goes
on where I would pick something that's
not meant to go together or might see
you know a pattern and an overlap with
something else to create a third meaning
and so on you know so they're kind of it
you know so the some private games going
on with the kind of fabrics and images I
choose you know because after all it's
got to be fun you know you
you know so so I need to manger will
process you know my walk you know so and
so there's a lot of kind of playful
things going on but when I twin it when
I just opposed things I'm wondering
whether there's also another dimension
in that fabric acts as a kind of
masquerade that with costumes and
appearance and the way that people can
manipulate their appearance and they did
in the 18th century yeah absolutely yeah
they can move beyond their social
station that they were born into is that
something in the back of your mind when
you're recreating these period costumes
well yes I mean indeed you know and as
you well know Carnival in the Caribbean
you know that was a day in which you
know the slaves could be the aristocrats
for a day and the aristocrats could be
whatever they wanted to be but it was
and you know kind of always is a way so
there's a process of transformation you
know and and costume or dress is a way
in which you can become something else
for a day at least you know yeah and the
way in which they're placed in the trees
with the headless mannequins draws
attention to the theatricality of
a dress as the kind of performance do
you see a correlation with our celebrity
culture today in you mentioned you know
the this affair of Nelson's that made
him a celebrity in contemporary eyes
were you drawing our attention to
something similar that's taking place in
the present well I mean all of my work
even when it appears historical is about
the present you know it's always about
you know I'm also going back to history
to find metaphors for the present you
know the present is to present if you
see what I mean to actually you know it
will come across in if I suddenly had
you know Kim Kardashian and all over my
work you know that would be that would
be to present you know I would have to
have other other other metaphors
yeah so the juxtaposition allows both
distance that there's a historical
dimension to it and also a commentary on
the present that there's indirect yeah
explain directly so moving on to the the
film and we have a clip coming up after
I've just perhaps ask a question to set
the scene this is a film you mentioned
verdes La Traviata of 1859 as well but
what was it that attracted you to the
medium of film and the moving image that
you couldn't have explored in an
installation or culture as culturally I
think there is something about
performance within cinema and within the
moving image and also the transformation
of the idea of time within film you know
you can't do things with time that you
cannot do in something which is static
you know and I like that and I like the
yes I just like what you can do with
time within cinema okay well let's run
the clip we have a brief clip from it
and then and sound of course
sound is important
so that was just as a brief extract yeah
but you've taken up Francis's point of
view so I want to know why your empathy
why your sympathies were with Francis
she's in the role of Violette from
verdes opera who's is expressing loss on
the eve of her death in the Opera but we
see the unopened letters that Horatio
Nelson returned to Francis what led you
to think of the film from Francis's
point of view well again on this
occasion I decided not to be on the side
of patriarchy I decided that you know
the oppressive nature of patriarchy in
terms of imperialism and misogyny was
not something I wanted to support so
that was one institution of power that
you didn't feel comfortable yes I did
not and was it the aesthetic qualities
of the Opera rather than the story that
attracted you to and I I think both I
also think that at the time of doing it
I was really contemplating they
literally the end of empire in a both
the end of the American and
by the end of the British Empire and the
way in a kind of a strange situation now
where there are other forces wanting to
take that position you know be it Russia
or China a bit but there is something
going on and so and and this is a film a
metaphor for exploring those in a way
because you do see the film is
constantly interrupted by the death of
Nelson you know there's one point where
he's jumping off a mountain and stabbing
himself at the same time you know so
there there is this so it's my way of
contemplating those things you know but
doing it through the cinema so you could
say that's she took the lead role
because I was exploring if you like the
death of patriarchy but in a protracted
and being a metaphor for the death of
Imperial parts although they definitely
producing yeah so as an allegory of loss
or impending loss yes it was embodied in
a female voice yes yeah yeah and there's
repetition that's involved you talked a
little bit about your interest in time
yes absolutely yes that led to your work
in film because repetition also features
in a mask ball which focuses on the
assassination of King Gustav the third
of Sweden at the end of the 18th century
yes
so were there filmmakers will film
practices that were influential for you
in terms of thinking about a cyclic or
rather than narrative time structure yes
there's film called the last days at
because I'm thinking there's some God
art films where things are constantly
repeated
you know French New Wave cinema and so
but you see the repetition in my films
are based on a kind of it's it's based
on mimicry of the loop so what I mean by
that is you know when you go into a
gallery a video is playing over and over
again it's on a loop it's a but it's the
same thing that just plays over again
over and over again but I wanted what I
wanted to do with this video is to have
the actors actually reenact something
again but when you go in you think oh
it's on a loop well when you look
closely you realize that no actually
it's not only loop they're actually
doing that the same thing again but
that's kind of strange because the
actors can never do the same act twice
so there's always a slight difference so
the Annie but it's also it's almost like
it's it's all it's it's a modernist
strategy where the form the process
becomes the art did you understand what
I'm trying to say yeah and the
repetition heightens one's appreciation
of these subtle variations yes
federación yeah but moving on to a sort
of parallel work from an earlier period
the mid to late 1990s but this again is
focused on that that turning point from
the year of enlightenment the French and
American revolutions in Trafalgar into
the nineteenth century but you're not
only challenging national histories of
Britain Britain British maritime history
but art history as well so what were
some of the decisions in the back of
your mind that led to the marriage
portrait by Thomas Gainsborough that
you're referencing in this sculpture of
1990
eight well you're looking at mr. and
mrs. Andrews painted by Gainsborough and
my version is mr. and mrs. Andrews
without their heads you know at the time
I was actually very much I was you know
very interested in the French Revolution
and I was also you know I showed a
strong interest in the guillotine and
and and I felt that you know I would I
would apply the guillotine to to history
and so mr. and mrs. Andrews without the
head you know the newlywed couple and
you can see their state in the
background and and you know how do they
make that money who you know who was
slaving away so they could have all that
so I took their state away and I chop
their heads off simple you know so
that's so that's what you see it isn't a
simple but also very striking in the
sense that is there a comment as well
about the emphasis on reason and
rationality in the Enlightenment well I
mean you know the Enlightenment is been
a lie in their way
I mean you know the I'm sitting here
speaking to you in English because of
the Enlightenment you know I'd rather be
speaking to you in your ver but I can't
do that you know I'm not a lot well I'm
allowed to do that but you know it's
complicated yes and you know it's a
little protest you know it's just like a
little protest you know this works
and it's a way of saying you know
actually perhaps we ought to value other
traditions as well about we are to you
know perhaps we
should not have the dominance of the
West in the same way because the
Enlightenment is being used as an excuse
to wipe out all cultures and whole you
know whole traditions and and not seeing
value in other traditions and so I can
you know challenge those things through
my work so something which proclaimed
the supremacy of Reason was actually
using unreasonable force and violence
absolutely yeah absolutely you know then
what is that they're like mint produced
in our nuclear weapons and guns no and
again it's bringing out that in a very
pointed way that dark side of modern
history making it available for
discussion without being didactic or
without closing down the narrative you
know absolutely yes as we come towards a
conclusion with the fake death pictures
the paper works we're looking at
something here which references the
death of chapter 2 the Romantic poet yes
by the pre-raphaelites painter
yes Wallace are you commenting also on
the romanticization of death well also
the romanticization of Nelson Nelson's
death in particular no there were all
kinds of myths surrounding his death and
Nelson is a kind of a sigil it almost
like a you know elevator to a
mythological figure in a way
mythological status and and I wanted to
I mean I've deliberately called those
fake death pictures because I you know I
was also interested in the mythology or
the kind of romantic idea about
somebody's death you know I mean that
person could be they could have been in
nastiest person when they were alive but
those are kind of the way that we kind
of romanticize their death and and the
whole myth around Nelson's death it's
also around that you know he was
was a hero why was a flawed hero without
that's not the bits that you know that
we like to emphasize or talk about and
there's a close relationship between
photography and painting here in the yes
photography is the medium valued for its
veracity its truth to lightness what
you're emphasizing though is something
that's contrary to that which is and we
can see it in the photo work that
references Manet's suicide of 1877 it's
the theatricality the fakery the
artifice yes yeah could you say more
about what photography allows you to do
as a medium well I mean I think it's the
tableau you know it's the tablet you
know and nature of photography you know
you can you know it's it's it's
theatrical and it's staged you know you
can stage something and you can light it
in a way that you want so you can and
it's the kind of you know tableau effect
that I feel I can achieve with
photography that you know and also you
know we don't usually pen those kinds of
pictures now but we can stage them you
know and but then this is also an
extension there's a correlation anywhere
between still photography like this and
cinema as well you know so and I often
will photograph in location if I want to
make a film and I would do my
storyboards using photography just take
something and actually if photography
came first and then it seemed like a
logical progression of the photography
to actually do film yeah and how were
you led to this work by a lens ax which
is it's a portrait of death twice
removed in the sense that it's a satire
of the romantic the romanticization of
death yes well I mean I think it you
know obviously it's it's kind of me kind
of also mocking myself and mocking you
know you know you set something up but
then you cancel what you set up as well
you know yeah it's kind of not taking
yourself too seriously
but also it's funny I mean you know and
it's absolutely ridiculous
what sort of coming full circle as we
come to an end you did mention earlier
on that a permanent home has been found
for nelson ship-in-a-bottle
at the National Maritime Museum which is
in a very historically rich site it's a
World Heritage Site
yeah and today there's a lot I mean I'm
interested on to ask you a question
about your the ethics of public art
because it's come under a great deal of
scrutiny today and there are those who
argue that sculptures that glorify the
imperial past or post histories of
slavery should simply be removed you're
offering an alternative but what's your
view on that firmly held view by some
that we should now dispense with these
reminders of of that dark history well
I don't think that we should be removing
things we don't like I think that I
wouldn't go into a library and take out
all the bad books just because I don't
like it I think that a lot of the very
painful historical images images of
slavery and so on I think that should
they should become tools of Education
you know I think that we should if we
removed all these things we'll risk
actually repeating those things and I
don't think that it's appropriate to
erase the bits of history that you
happen not to like I and clearly the
people who advocate the removal of these
things will probably wouldn't support
going into libraries and taking out all
the bad books well there might be an
argument that the books are not as
visible on a daily basis but I still
believe that to remove those things
would be three erase history therefore
to risk a repetition of those grotesque
events so the irony and the playfulness
that you've evoked previously as an
indispensable aspect of your aesthetic
strategy is really ethically and
politically conceptualized as well it
enables us to talk about these painful
histories absolutely you know I mean I
want people to explore the history of
the Battle of Trafalgar through this
ship in a bottle
you know and through the past we
understand up today if we were to erase
the past how then do we understand our
today
yeah so let's end on the question about
tomorrow in the sense that I know can
you share with us a little bit about the
Commission that you recently received
from the National Museum of
african-american history and culture and
as it relates the Smithsonian was your
mother African oh my mistake sorry yeah
can you tell us a little bit about that
Commission yes so after doing the
ship-in-a-bottle
the process of working on the sales
generated new ideas for public sculpture
and they are more playful they're called
wind sculptures and they're made of
fiberglass and they're painted
fiberglass with steel armatures in the
in in the middle of them and so I have
the wind sculptures you know over five
meters tall and I have them you know
there's one on permanent display in
London near Victoria Station
yep let's go how it plays and you know
so one of my the wind sculptures will be
on permanent display outside the
Smithsonian Museum of African art so
that's the commission that you're
talking about
yeah well allow me to express
congratulations for that and also to say
that we have an opportunity to ask
individual questions to young care at
the reception that's taken place over
the road at the Yale Center for British
art but for now please join me in
thanking English on the bar
you